National University is a primarily
Online private university based in
California it enrolls around 45
000 students currently and targets adult
Learners who are returning to higher
education as well as veterans and active
military members
well National first piqued our interest
because it was one of only 31 colleges
that scored an A-Plus on our annual
college financial grades list and it was
the only one of those that we'd never
heard of before so after doing some
research and talking to the leadership
there we found that National which is a
non-profit University actually follows a
really similar business model to
for-profit colleges which really
contributed to their financial success I
think what we do at National and a lot
of other good actors should do in the
non-profit space in higher education is
put the student at the Forefront of
everything we do and it's not that
different than running a business where
you put the customer first and use what
are the needs of the customer what are
the
um the things that you need to do to
make sure that their experience is an
amazing experience that it meets them
where they are and it actually fulfills
the promise that brand promise that you
you make to that customer well that's
same thing in education so what we do is
we meet our students where they they
need to be met as I mentioned before
many of our students are our older
students they haven't been in school for
a while so they need a lot of coaching a
lot of nudging a lot of extra mentoring
I think our secret sauce is our faculty
that are basically their sole main
responsibility is teaching uh with the
student and mentoring the student and
making sure that they soon have all the
all the tools that they need to succeed
so it takes a lot of people uh to create
a great environment for learning for our
students Michael Cunningham is National
University's Chancellor and he also runs
system Management Group which is the
business unit that runs National
University as well as National Sister
colleges he got a start in business in
the printing industry when he opened
Cunningham Graphics International which
is a company that printed analystic
research reports in the year 2000 he
sold the company to automatic data
processing for 136 million and he went
back to school for his PhD and has
worked in higher education ever since
under Cunningham's leadership National
has grown from about 33 000 students to
forty five thousand he's also LED their
transition from a hybrid online
in-person model to primarily online
which has really helped National out
during the pandemic since the university
already had the digital learning
infrastructure it needed to quickly
pivot to online meanwhile most colleges
and universities were just creating or
scaling up their digital offerings and
National already had it in place impact
without scale is good but it's not great
what we want to do is have impact with
scale number one it creates so many more
opportunities for students around the
world and it transforms Society because
if you change one person's life you
change their life forever if you change
thousands of people's lives forever you
change society for the better forever
and unfortunately uh there's a hard
truth the cost of acquisition of student
acquisition is very expensive
so what we want to do when we're doing
right now is creating economy of scale
so that we reduce the cost by growing
the organization so the cost to our
students goes down our goal is to
continually reduce pricing this last
year we reduced our net tuition prices
by over 20 percent
Michael is an academic
which is
which he's also not been afraid to make
some controversial decisions either
including changing programs and cunning
faculty which is typically met with a
lot of pushback and not every leader can
follow through on it if you think about
it we're we're experiencing a period of
punctuated equilibrium and basically
what it means is when when you have an
equilibrium in any business or in any
Enterprise or Society for that matter
and things are at steady state and then
something jolts that steady state and
changes things that creates a lot of
hardship but it also creates opportunity
so previously in my business we were
Printing and then Distributing but with
digital technology we were able to
distribute electronically first around
the world and then print locally
So It sped up our our response time from
four days around the world to one day
and it brought the cost down by 25 so
what we're happening right now if you
think about it the same digital paradigm
shift is happening throughout society
and then on top of that we had the
pandemic
and then overnight whole society was
jolted and and people were working
remotely people were learning remotely
trying to figure it out and we were in a
position because we've been doing it
online for a long time education online
we were one of the first movers in the
space we were able to use that
opportunity to expand our business
expand our footprint and expand the
value of our proposition to students not
only our existing students but uh new
entrance to the marketplace